[Music]
started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Lisa Park and it's genuine
pleasure to welcome you to our event
tonight which is the CMS colloquium and
Civic Arts lecture series the event is
supported by conservative media studies
in writing ATT and the global media
technologies and cultures lab as well as
the professor Jim Paradis who's over
here I also want to say thanks to the
research decisions in my lab that did a
lot of work to help make this doesn't
happen and as well as Mauricio Cordero
who has designed this poster and all of
the posters for the series is on so our
speaker today is filmmaker educator and
community journalist and activist
Myron's Dewey my ring is hi huge
shoshone from the Walker River Paiute
Tribe in the great great basement area
of Nevada Myron has worked in the field
of information technology since 1997 in
2003 he started a business called
digital smoke signals that focused on
computer and Internet consulting he then
went on to finish a master's degree in
indigenous studies at the University of
Kansas and has worked for many years on
digital language preservation and what
he calls the indigenous nation of
technology and media his IT work has
always had a social dimension and has
addressed youth education gender-based
violence and tribal sovereignty issues
among many other issues thousands of
people around the world became familiar
with Myron Dewey's were during the
Dakota access oil pipeline protests on
the Standing Rock reservation in 2016
and 17 using live-streaming drums and
social media Myron with other drone
activists such as steam dead men work
creatively and tirelessly to use the
sovereign airspace above tribal lands to
witness and copper Energy Partners
infrastructural incursions onto the
territories of the Standing Rock
Asia including on the sacred burial
grounds much of my own duties were
documented the standoffs between
peaceful water protectors and heavily
militarized county state and federal law
enforcers together with privatized
security eight teams of Titus why do we
use Facebook live to keep his relatives
near and far it warmed about what was
happening from an indigenous perspective
and went on to direct a documentary film
called awake a dream from standing walk
standing rock which we screened on
campus last night and which also
premiered at the Tribeca Film Festival
in 2017 and is available online and I
strongly encourage you to see the film
if you haven't seen it yet and to share
it with friends family and others that
might be interested on the face of
subject film art he's also recently been
invited to teach a class on a spring at
Duke University in the process of doing
the work he did it standing wrong he had
30 Thrones destroyed or confiscated and
faced the charge of stalking which means
even talk to us a bit about tonight some
have referred to drums to Dewey's drone
activism and the new form of tactical
media as it is involved the art of
getting access hacking the power and
disappearing at the right moment but it
is also important to note that
indigenous media have always been
tactical media long before digital
mirrors and media theorists came up with
this concept and are arguably the first
form of media though I was one of the
thousands of people watching Myron's
coverage of the Davos protest I have a
privilege of meeting him in person
earlier this year when we served on a
panel
there are brown University called sue
surveillance and to prepare for our
event I read many law enforcement and
FAA records related to related standing
rock protests that were released in FOIA
requests Freedom of Information Act
request as I wanted to understand the
state and private surveillance and
militarization practices that had been
mobilized against peaceful water
protectors at Standing Rock these
policing practices have been aimed at
Myron de left directly on multiple
occasions and he's endured a great deal
and has many stories to tell he's also
just returned from Mexico where he
travelled for a week with the so called
migrant caravan in order to witness and
document what is happening for his
tribal elder what is not happening for
him so he can communicate that to his
tribal elders we are extremely fortunate
to have why we do we here with us
tonight and I'd like you to join me in
giving him a warm welcome
her mother Nanea
ho Bachchan I mean a guy to cut na na ki
bholi atewa Bijan know my Ottawa as I
introduced my name and thank everyone
for being here and I wanted to open up
in my language to let you know that we
still have our language here and I want
to thank Lisa for acknowledging the
tribes the land that we're on it's very
important that the community know no
matter where you go throughout the
United States you're on Indian land and
the tribes are still there there's over
five hundred and sixty-eight federally
recognized tribes and right now the
tribes are trying to hold on to their
federal status which is the trust
responsibility between the United States
and the tribes trust relationship which
is being threatened by this
administration as you guys know what the
whopper dog nation so with this we'll
start with want to start you guys off
with a little bit of the media that I
witnessed growing up on the reservation
was which was not a presence in the
indigenous communities which was native
media in Nevada is a great example we
have two military bases on both sides of
our reservation and we still don't have
native media or native radio or native
TV there and so my goal is to we're at a
time now where we have access so instead
of saying we can't it's like what can we
do and what you guys are witnessing is
this is what we can do let's create the
solutions that we have access to right
now which right now the window and media
and social media is closing its closing
fairly fast an example was shadow
blocking which is happening now on
social media which I documented and I'm
trying to document this in real time so
those who are witnessing can actually
see what's happening and how to
counteract it to get the media out my
goal to go down to Mexico was to make
sure that our indigenous people got a
voice and to go witness what was
happening so our people here can
understand it from an indigenous
perspective what we are seeing something
that our journalists down there when I
was down there with the El Salvadorian
Caravan there was only two journalists
and they were not active they were only
filming and I asked them so what are you
guys doing are you volunteering or do no
we don't we don't we don't bother nobody
we just do our thing well our goal was
to establish communication down there
but we call it the point nabhi the point
idea is when that goes ahead to scout
ahead so when the rest of the tribe
comes they're gonna be in a safe area or
safe position and safe place and what I
witnessed at Standing Rock was an
example of what I'm seeing now in Mexico
we seen corporate militarization having
the funding at a low budget and the
militarization of putting around the war
putting a wall around the pipeline what
I'm gonna see happening down and this
border is it's an excuse it feels like a
politically motivated agenda - exactly
what happened to us being demonized and
considered jihadist terrorists that's
what we were considered as Danny Rock -
down here at the border they're already
starting to demonize them coming across
the border so I had to show people who
they were women children and elders
there was some handicap wearing Crocs
wear sandals some people are educated
some people were fleeing for their lives
for particular reasons to educate and
get a fight a better life for their
community
and the only way to do it is to go on
the ground and in the area we were in I
really learned a lot and that short
amount of time I learned that I can't
film just anywhere because we were a
narco territory if you guys are familiar
with that it's people who can kidnap you
for sex trafficking organ harvesting I
mean just unreal I felt like I was in my
own movie again and and I really was it
really broke my heart to see that to
know that our relatives are being
kidnapped and to hear the stories of
them like if you were here one or two
you'd be kidnapped and it really just
kind of broke my heart seeing the
children and there's no defense and so
what they were doing is traveling
together as tight as they possibly could
I don't seen an escalation from Standing
Rock which is the testing ground
it's a spark that spark from that sacred
fire
for many people they needed that part
but what I'm seeing it's the bigger
picture this is something for the last
500 years we've witnessed and
we learned as a family together in the
United States that we're not acting as
we're seeing that divide now and when
I'm asking people to help I'm like don't
get political either if you're
indigenous I want to know how you can be
a good relative because I'm down there
for the eagle and the Condor prophecy
that predates can kiss the door and
colonialism if you're in a non-native
how can you be a good Ally and if you
have no religion or your anarchist you
know how can you be just a good human
being to help people that need help that
are less fortunate than us right now at
this moment and what we're seeing is
this propaganda media that was the goal
to go down and contradict counteract it
and debunk it and do it in a live stream
where there's no cutting and editing so
for two hours straight I would film
here's what I see and just kind of
narrate a little bit about what I'm
witnessing so coming from Stanny rock
you know the drones I did fly drones
down there and I had to do it
differently so I did it right in the
open right in front of the officers and
I just was like I'm just gonna do it
like I belong here and they kind of
liked it and I just you know give him an
Indian nod like that they didn't know
what to think they just kind of you know
but they got machine guns on you know
I'm thinking I didn't want to cause any
conflict so you know you asked and I
asked and they didn't know they look at
each other no comprende so I flew and
they thought it was really cool and I
was able to document from another
perspective queen up wouldn't you which
I call Eagle Eye and to share that
perspective with you guys through
indigenous eyes and to go right in there
and document people close and share with
them and some of them we did interviews
with and I brought shirts with the eagle
and the Condor and digital smoke signals
logos so they can hashtag where their
journey is so we could follow them and
make sure they're safe along their route
so luckily it's not escalating to to
this part yet which it will and this is
what I'm worried about
yes Oh
we're gonna start from right here this
is the beginning of a story that was
being told oh what's going on here we
got a little bit of spam a story that
was told by LaDonna we're storytellers
indigenous people and in the beginning
of the camp I walked around to create
digital storytellers and if most of the
youth have technology already they
already have phones snapchat Instagram I
did not have to teach them it's the
elders that I got to teach it so all the
people that are scared to break it and
it was it's always been frustrating to
to realize that we have a generation
technically hat in Indian country and
they don't want to learn technology and
that's okay because we need those elders
to help us and guide us with that
information so the youth just picked it
right up and I crowdsource the youth and
walked around and made sure that they
just shared their story as community
journalists many were worried like we're
not journalists or we're gonna be
attacked for doing this and I'm like
you're telling your story we're in any
country and now you're both important to
share your voice share your teachings
explain to these people that are
watching that we're not who they're
saying we are
provide all of their information I think
she wants to be first and the tribe has
ten days to respond to that and so there
will be a hearing in February I would
like to put accent down $20 a week so
with us that is a good thing it is not
[Music]
secrets don't won't be standing we need
ask everybody who want to continue to
stand we believe that the decision
have you seen
[Music]
we need to stand out for their chicken
we ask the people control the nation we
have a right to know people have a right
to
to
that photo that's that right here would
not seem like anything unless you
understood that where they're standing
up on the top is burial sites that's
where they occupied and so when I go
through and to share with you guys what
we're seeing in consistent media here
and in a synchronized voice I also
wanted you guys to see that what I put
in here is the the barricade
that had the layers that they had dug
and what they put around with Casselton
wire and there was no archaeologists
there was no cultural monitor that
tribes have to make sure that they they
don't disturb our sacred sites which
they desecrated sicker sighs they didn't
disturb they desecrated and I knew that
I needed to document this as much as I
hurt as a cultural monitor to go in
document this is what I originally got
into drones was to protect our sacred
sites and where they went through they
nobody would have known if they did go
through sacred sites or disturbed
anything but what you're seeing is their
makeshift wall and when I share with you
guys the Constitution wire they had it
for four miles around the their drill
site not just right here but around the
property and they had a pit that was
about eight feet wide and like twelve
feet down that they also dug and they'd
have two different layers down here with
concertina wire and it goes all the way
around on top on the bottom and in the
hole if you can see it going into the
hole so it's in case you fall in there
you're also gonna get trapped what I'm
seeing is that this is gonna be shipping
containers now at the border that's just
what I'm experiencing because now we
have a budget of US dollars this is
corporate budget right here what you're
seeing with mercenaries and so I wanted
to share that with you guys because and
document it in real time I could see it
wasn't this is a pattern of history with
indigenous people so I had to make sure
that
we had training as much people even our
allies that come in to hold them
accountable when and when not to film
the thing about filming is that we don't
film our ceremony so there was a lot of
ceremonies happening and so there's some
media that just got a film they just got
to get it got their camera like this
even after you tell them please don't
film they just they got their audio on
it doesn't matter and so what I started
to find the I knew what the problem was
and the solution was to educate our
allies it's like okay you need to hold
yourself accountable because I always
share how do we hold ourselves
accountable for our forefathers promises
it is not your fault what happened to
the indigenous people but it is your
responsibility to hold yourself
accountable that's how I feel and the
thousands that came that's what I was
hearing them say I'm here to hold my
family accountable so when I'm just
sharing with you is what I heard from
allies coming through and so this is how
I want to express to you is how we start
to heal as indigenous people as allies
because obviously we're not gonna go
anywhere we're holding our land and one
way to start the healing is together we
got to acknowledge the atrocities
survivors day who doesn't know what that
means it is Thanksgiving that's what it
is it's not a it's not a it's for
indigenous people it's not a happy day
and it's a sad day we survived so it's
it's different for indigenous people so
it's not a celebration and some are
moving past that and there they are
using it to celebrate with families to
be a family and changing the narrative
of it but that's the goal is to educate
and empower through here do we have a
question from about the video you guys
just saw open up for a few questions and
I'll go to the next one
yes that'll be right here now I guess we
can we can start with that then and then
I can answer your question on how the
video is being used as a visual legal
narrative awake the documentary was
being used as a visual legal narrative
because what they were doing was taking
our videos and creating Facebook
felonies and the charge that I got was I
actually called in on 911 that we were
being stalked by Dakota access
mercenaries and I got the call because I
caught him on the drone in the live feed
and I came up and they were sent up on
the hill and I and I popped up around
him and I got their license place and I
got their pictures and we were able now
we knew who was up on the hill
and I've got pictures in South beats of
snipers you know it had to show him hey
this is real I got a life bead work I
was in full mesh and you know this is
what we're dealing with was community
warfare down there so it was like I was
having to show a thirst
Tiger Swan here there's mercenaries here
how did I catch them I walked up to them
and asked him for directions on a live
feed and and he wasn't so scary when he
started talking he kind of really
sounded he'll hillbilly well shoot you
know and I was like he's just normal he
just but he looked all meshed up you
know and we laughed and talked and I got
him on a live feed and you could
probably go back and watch it and then
we left and I had a reporter from the
Navajo times with me and he was in the
military and he said that's the only
time I really puckered up you know he's
you actually witnessed these guys
they're fully fully opted up no license
plates on their vehicle he says you know
that that looks like Blackwater and
there's his notice Tiger Swan you know
that's in Blackwater but it's the new
name tigress Wan this is what we have to
be prepared for but they weren't as
dangerous in the in in a sense in front
of us okay what was dangerous was the
militia that nobody was controlling that
was dangerous people trying to come in
and create problems the infiltration was
dangerous and also our own people that
are colonized that are in the military
that came two of them were Kyle Thompson
being one who was through philia tribes
there and he was actually the gunman
with the ar-15 so there is the
complications there but that's history
and Indian Wars and this is the reason
explain you as a visual legal narrative
the next day Martin County denied that
they used anything there any weapons any
water
there was a total of 300 that were
injured but 150 were documented
[Music]
[Music]
second one we're going to look at today
is what the social media and a lot of
individuals out here are commonly
referred to as tear gas the actual main
port is CS gas and this is designed for
crowd control and to assist law
enforcement and deploy a munition and
trying to get to the plants through the
effects of the ages as you can see that
as split into several rounds and those
are designed to disperse into the crowd
to help garner the control of a large
crowd the next device we're going to
show you is what's called a flash
diversionary device and this book
commonly referred to on social media as
a percussion or a concussion grenade and
the collect remind our viewers that at
no point kind of enforcement deploy
these devices
[Applause]
from it being their enemy and within
seconds hitch blown up or shadow might
run over and the track will need to see
like closer scruple from her leg
from there I was already go with your
shop ahead forgive myself I know how to
maintain that type of stress it's very
traumatic
so that was a many that was a visual
legal narrative hopefully down the road
we're gonna have somebody that said
baloo able to hold them accountable for
the human rights violations and the
constitutional violations that we
witnessed that was done as a live feed
in real time the three drones were shot
down documenting that they had their own
drone up on top and I felt that I also
document documented a weaponized drone
because something came from down and I
have it in a video of a shooting
straight down it might not have been a
type of gun but it seemed like it was
more of could have been weaponized with
a rubber bullet or something but I only
got it coming down and the drone was
sitting out in the ice I had a water
protector wanting to go get it - I think
nah man we don't need any more people
getting hurt you know people are hurt
bad enough and stories like this to
document was like a repeating history
that was happening that worse also I'm
correlating with the border is because
if you guys don't believe what's
happened in there just take a trip to
the border for one day go in go down
walk around and you're gonna run into
militia you're gonna run into the
military there's 5,000 soldiers that
were deployed you're gonna start to see
the console team wire you're gonna also
see your rights as a citizen how far can
you go and most people don't exercise
how far they can go they kind of stop
and how far can you go you know and what
is your rights so the day I pulled in to
Mexico City
the second caravan which was coming in
from Honduras and I didn't I don't know
Spanish but only the bad words so you
know it's like I kind of had to I have a
lot of translators that were translating
but we also have put disclaimers because
one of the one of the things again it
was our own people that took out of
context the word and made something out
of it to social media and what it did is
a cost confusion that I was promoting
that we were Joe I don't know if Jehovah
sort or one of the five tribes or eight
tribes I don't even know the religion
has I think that's Mormonism and that
wasn't our agenda our agenda is to
amplify the message of why they're down
there just to witness what we're seeing
so our people appear can actually say
okay now we know that someone on the
ground this is what they're seeing and
we put a disclaimer back up there saying
this is not a we're just documenting and
the translators translating there's
different speakers and there was many
different speakers and this just shows
them coming in
this shows him coming in and everyone
was pretty excited there was I believe
7,200 people on both sides appear in the
stadium down on the middle and then on
the other side these tents were these
tents were these tents were filled with
women and children behind him and I
actually walked down there and I shared
with them who knew about the eagle and
the Condor prophecy which many of them
did know and we talked about it and I
stuck out like a sore thumb I mean there
was not a hole I'll be pretty short
people you know so I felt kind of like I
I couldn't maneuver like I was at
Standing Rock you know there I was
really sticky now and they says India
India was and called me original I was
the original here so it was very uh just
to document what was going on right here
to know there's a lady her name is
birdie that's on the by the San Diego
area and she's on the Mexican side
trying to put all these camps and safety
and get him ready and I just I just kind
of it just really broke my heart to to
see indigenous people have to leave
their homes this way and pick up only
what they could carry and then just go
and I wanted just to make sure that they
understood that you know the indigenous
people know they're coming and they've
been colonized once we've been colonized
I'm speaking to you in a colonized
language so they've been colonized and
they're gonna come to another country
and be recolonized and so it's important
that I know that in this in the
education system they're not going to
teach them the indigenous history the
atrocities the sexual abuse that
happened with the church the violence
the force of loss of language loss of
land loss of dignity they're not going
to teach them those things where it came
from so I want to prepare them for that
the discrimination the racism that
they're going to encounter the political
systemic racism they're going to
encounter in the
education the kidnapping of their
children that happened to us I want to
prepare them for these for this journey
that they're coming to and I don't know
if people are doing that and I'm trying
to work with people down there to say we
need to be down there but we also have
to make ourself have a presence down
there and to remand to let them know
that you know we're matriarchy tribes
we're not a patriarchy so it's important
that they recognize that so these values
come in here and two into Indian country
we call it I still call it Indian
country no matter where I go it's a new
country to me and I'm indigenous to this
land and I'm going to share that with
them and that's what I try to do in a
good way to educate and prepare them for
this journey this is another one to
answer your question on the FAA is the
FAA denied any drones were being shot
and I had a meeting with the FAA and I
shared with them that this Lindt this
this airspace is tribal airspace and
it's sovereign and he kind of disagreed
and and I said well they're shooting the
drones it was a hey hey - that's kind of
hearsay and I had it ready on my iPad
and this is what I showed them
they survey on the construction of
overhead documenting the pipelines have
from sacred sites and providing Intel to
protesters who call themselves water
collectors they're actually now this is
how close they are to the river
barricade around see that see that you
see that he just got it
they're drones are almost shot at like
police who along with private security
or a constant presence around this
portion of the 72
[Music]
so the guy that was talking was a medic
and he came back and was telling me
they're aiming as they're pulling people
at pulling people out hitting them in
the butt
and he got hit in the butt a couple of
times and as they were holding their
hands up they were hitting them in the
hands shooting their hands and they
thought the women were kind of you know
dressed bundled up were men they were
hitting them in the crotch and they were
hitting and kneecaps they were aiming to
hurt people two main people that's what
they were doing and I interviewed one of
the medics that was there on the ground
and this is what we're trying to
document in the human rights violations
the constitutional violations but this
didn't have really there was already a
barricade there was wire there they
could have actually left but what I've
seen the difference between here and in
Mexico City was women were all inside
the inside the stadium the energy was
different nobody was really tense on the
outside though it was completely
different the men were on the outside
and energy was a lot different so so
with that one that kind of gives you I
hope that answers your question on
creating a visual legal narratives and I
did a call-out for drone pilots I did
drone training tried to do as much as I
can and walking around and doing lifee
training created a women's indigenous
media group and try to empower the women
as much as we possibly could so we have
a different voice of elders to speak
young people to speak allies to speak
and to indigenized the media to let them
know they're in any country and the
language you're using you have to
relearn what that what kind of leg
were talking about with sovereignty and
treaty and inherent rights and kind of
re-educating America they're reading the
media and digitizing the media on
indigenous 101 which is not easy guys
you know we're taught a certain way to
to ignore all those things and when it
comes time for us to fight and we're in
DC or in front of a March like what are
these Indians doing here
well we're 90% in front of the
environmental fights in every action you
go to across the country and the
violence against women was on our
indigenous women first started with
Lewis and Clark and it escalated all the
way up from the Mayflower and they just
kept going and going to where we are
today with the Dakota access and the man
camps so these man camps are real we
documented them there and what I've seen
in Mexico was oil pipelines down in the
cartel area and I documented them as
well and what I'm seeing is that though
there is no the violence the missing
murdered indigenous women start from
Canada United States
now I'm getting flooded with messages
that are indigenous women from United
States are getting stolen into Mexico
but there's no one documenting the women
in Mexico from here and I know they are
in Mexico but we don't have that there's
a language barrier here and we're not
sharing that and so we need to get with
our relatives from the south and the
north and in the middle and combine that
those statistics because these
extraction companies aren't both sides
of the border and what I know from being
in this educating about the oil
pipelines is that Kelsey Warren's trying
to go to Mexico that's what I know
and I know he's doing it from the Texas
area and that is his goal can for use
smart MIT business guys I need you to
guys help articulate the subsidiaries of
this company of these of how business is
done because it creates subsidiary
companies to hide their parent company
and it's kind of similar to the tribes
immunity in taxation but they've figured
out how to do it corporately and that's
what we need to do is to stop them from
doing that and these parent companies
and these subsidiary companies
so Kelsey Warren is the owner of the
Dakota access pipeline with many
subsidiary companies energy transfer
they did not own the land when they put
this burial when they went over burial
sites there as well he's the one that
has he lives in Texas his house has been
protested many times and he Trump
endorsed the Dakota access pipeline his
second day in office these guys shares
in the Dakota access pipeline the man
camps are when all these pipelines are
being built they bring them all in into
one area and all men all that false
masculinity toxicity they're the one
there when their downtime is that's
where the missing murdered indigenous
women is from these man camps and so we
need to try to find better ways to
protect our communities and maybe you
guys may have seen him there's a lot of
stories about man camps there's a lot of
shows about man camps drugs the the
there's no accountability and they put
them across jurisdiction so there's no
accountability again what I seen in with
Morton County is they would not cross
that line if it was the res you know and
so that's why we had to hold them
accountable because they were on treaty
land and these United States has not
honored a treaty yet so again I'm asking
you guys you know how do you have your
forefathers honor either your honor your
forefathers promises - the commitment to
the indigenous people once that's done
then we can start the healing you'll
understand that we can start to believe
that this is gonna happen the education
there is no amount of money that can be
contributed back to the indigenous
people lesson 2.3 percent of us are left
we're almost extinct so you amount of
money it's not gonna do anything for us
it actually kills us
the money that we get pennies on the
dollar for our land and our water this
is for some of this you guys this may be
new but if you go out to the Navajo
Nation you want to Paiute Nation out
Nevada Shoshone Nation the Standing Rock
tribe where there's mining coal mining
there's nuclear test sites Yucca
Mountain there's an indigenous prayer
trying to protect the water and how do
we know cuz we're connected to the land
we're connected to the traditional
medicines the food sources and when they
start migrating when they stop moving in
those directions or the water starts
flowing or we can't drink it something's
wrong there and so with this I was
hoping to get a visual legal narrative
so we could have some accountability
that we didn't have before this is uh
one of the other drone pilots prolific
and he was flying in the very beginning
he came down to make a video and ended
up getting charged seven years and so I
really seen like I've seen him like well
my little brother and you know I seen
him he was really upset and you know
never been to jail and hasn't has a
family and he didn't know what he was
gonna do and I said well you got to
finish it
you know we got a we've got to make you
famous we've got to literally make you
famous to get your to get your message
out there to say here's what they
they're saying that he flew into a
airplane with the drone that's what he
was doing they said and what prolific
did was he put together his own defense
and we got audio from different
locations and we scouted people who had
footage that was at the action and what
we what it came down to and the court
was that the judge after he allowed him
to show his own testimony and his own
information his own documentation his
own forensics and we had audio that
shared the officer told him that it was
illegal for him to fly underneath 500
feet which is a violation of FAA
regulations it is illegal for you to fly
a drone over 500 feet and so the judge
threw his case out which I thought is it
very important to share with you that
this is no longer the 1800s you know we
were very well prepared in Western law
international law treaty law and
inherent law to protect our people while
we were there because we've been going
through this so much this is a map of
the routes these our train routes that
there they're traveling and they're
taking the left side because our the
right side because it's shorter this is
what we're trying to tell them is don't
go to Mexico this is where the
militarization is the mercenaries and
they're in border towns now to which
were documented people the actual are in
these border towns are saying they're
here in these towns and the long way is
they're making it up there to Tijuana
and Juarez so they're making it there
and but they're getting there and now
I'm seeing something that happened at
Standing Rock there's a little clip of
what the camps came to big when the
veterans showed up Austin there's a
little bit of chaos and the information
wasn't reaching its area in time and so
I'm seeing that happen in there and so
how do we get communication and mighty
thinkers I want you guys to brainstorm
you know how do we get communication on
the ground how do we get communication
to protect the women and the children
there and the transgender that are there
and the two-spirit people that are
getting attacked there how do we protect
them from being harassed or if there's
any infiltrators this is a repeating
history though this is every movement
they're gonna send in infiltrators who I
did see there they're clean-cut a
certain way their posture was a certain
way it reminded me of the the
militarization that was our standing up
when they sit in infiltrators and you
can kind of spot them
you know when I documented the FBI that
was trying to be undercover that it was
really interesting and he was asking me
so how did you see me you know how did
you know I was I was FBI I said well you
were no longer part of the circle you
weren't part of the prayer you know you
weren't in sync with us you were here
for your own agenda and it wasn't the
collective so that's how we're able to
tell and I want to make sure they're
safe from that because that's not what
they want but I know what we're gonna do
what we're gonna get is propaganda media
all here their violence Standing Rock
had journalists taking pictures of only
trash and that made it out and we had to
put another video out were secrets
Stone had actually cleaned up one of the
largest year village in the world they
had completely cleaned it out completely
clean and there was a lot of that
happening in Oh Shetty and rosebud the
cleaning of the camps but what they did
is they piled all the snow and big old
piles that create a big old big old mud
pits so everyone was getting stuck so we
had to counteract the media with that
and that's what we got to do here is to
just show people on the ground what's
happening and why we need to help them
what is a solution what is the solution
to people that need help to turn them
away is that who we are as indigenous
people that's not who I am so I'm gonna
just do what I can to show people as a
good relative this is what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna show my cousin's my family the
technology part so this is what they had
there and I thought that was kind of
crazy when I saw that they were all
piled around 20 people and so we went
and got a board which was hard to find
boards that was a $40 board believe it
or not it's like probably four bucks
here and bought a bunch of plug-ins for
them to start charging and then in the
middle is gonna be a little flyer for
hashtags and which media to follow and
whose hit that trail before them and
just to be in safety and what you need
to know about your rights so we need to
educate as much as we possibly can to
educate the people that are there and
they're gonna go in different areas of
the camp and people what I learned too
there is they don't want to come the
United States not everyone wants to come
here many of them did stay in Mexico and
got asylum in Mexico some of them only
want to come the United States for two
years they don't want to stay they just
want to make enough money to go and go
home and and rebuild their lives some of
them want to go to Canada so there's
this misconception and I and if this
administration can take its time to just
go and talk and ask them what is it they
need and what is it they can do to work
with them then there'd be a different
understanding so this is right after the
first Caravan
left I went back and I saw them they
were cleaning everything up after having
7,200 people there after that the the
first video I showed where they were all
coming in it looked like it was trash
all over and by time we were done
interview and it was all clean
they had these crazy little witch brooms
you know look like straw and they were
like sweeping everywhere up and it was
it was all clean I was really really
surprised so these are the videos that
you guys can go through into creating a
digital footprint of digital
storytelling through indigenous ice and
the goal is to just empower people to be
community journalists and to share your
story and to empower your circle around
you and be a part of the collective and
not as an individual the individual part
is the Dakota access pipeline individual
wealth individual corruption and greed
that we witnessed and as and these
corporations are coming in like that but
if you can come in as a collective and
we can do this together and we can heal
together I just want you guys to know
that I'm open for that but I also want
to prepare you that not of our not a lot
of our Indian people are ready for
healing there's been so much atrocities
done that were all at different layers
of healing and able to articulate the
anger able to articulate the hurt and
the pain that happened and we still have
those stories that have been from
Western cultures ancestors or
encroachment and we're still having them
today happening so with that just do
what you can to educate yourself and
empower yourself to learn about who we
are as indigenous people definitely on
which land you walk upon it is your
responsibility to educate yourself it
Google the land that you're on pick a
tribe and then try to find somebody I
don't believe there's any more
Massachusetts tribe but there's Pequots
there's whoppin OGG nation there's
there's tribes where you can go and say
you know I'm I need to know and and I'm
again I apologize ahead of time if you
don't get received the way I'm
explaining to you because we're all at
different level of healing the
atrocities that have
done have been not held any
accountability as we seen a standing
rock so I'm hoping that you guys will
take that responsibility of holding
yourself accountable to honor your
forefathers promises and I want to say
you know it's hard to say I forgive you
but that's what we need to do and it's
got to be equally received because we
did a lot of things to survive as well
and we did what we could and the
veterans that came they did that they
did a healing ceremony and they forgave
all of Bismarck they said we're sorry
what we what we were sorry for what we
did and we also forgive you for what you
did and so with that guys I want to say
thank you the P genom the possession
knew my tsunami no my Ottawa my boy the
spirit were good mind good words good
spirit he shot you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I speak Spanish I understand why it is a
I don't understand completely but I
understand why my parents came here so
from that perspective I I I never
understand why they're coming out here
yeah that's all I had was my phone
that's it I mean I brought other
equipment in case it got dark it's more
of like I bought it on indigo which is a
crowdsourcing of this camera was the
building you can do in low-light and I
bought that just in case but I just did
live streaming I now would have left all
my stuff and just I brought two phones
just in case one was stolen I also had
prepared for it case I got kidnapped
because of journalists the stories that
I heard down there
my GPS so people know who where I was I
was also GPS in my locations to certain
particular people in the states to an
attorney
and I just prepared and the brother that
I had that was up there he was a water
protector and he had his I gave him a
call and he answered the call on camera
and walked with me you are from Standing
Rock through Mexico and he had his own
challenges you know so I had to find
somebody that was on the ground that was
there and he when we got into cartel an
area that was the that was the part well
I would say oh this is beautiful
beautifully dangerous you know don't
look at certain people don't look at the
cops what are you doing Meyer and you
know it's like I was getting a really a
lesson your phone is important what you
have already is mobile media that is
what's important and I had another lens
for this set is about this is how long
it is it's long lens for my camera you
can buy them on Amazon for like $19 for
your phone yep telephoto so keep it
simple well this is more technology than
NASA had when they launched the first
man of the Moon so we can use it and you
can use it on multiple platforms and you
can get your story out visually you can
articulate it through video media social
media blogging you just have to do it
and if you just consistent hashtag eagle
in the condor caravan is what we use I
had these made in two days down there so
I wanted to stimulate the local economy
as well
how do you support Mexico Mexico
supported their the people coming
through and they were saying thank you
to Mexico all the time there so these
were made by hand and I had a whole
bunch of a made like 500 and insurance
as well but with the hashtag so I can
start the communication process so it
was more than that community journalism
is being a part of the community that's
what it's about so I went across I was
in transparent as transparency as
possible so my goal was to go to make
sure you're self-reliant make sure you
know you have another phone the
communication part make sure you have
plenty of dollars pesos because I hear
we we actually got to one of the last
check points and we'd have no money to
cross and I don't know what else and I
didn't have no more money on me but yeah
pesos and my credit card they charge me
$50 three swipes 150 and at the Holiday
Inn which sees my credit card I maxed my
credit card to go there and I just says
ma'am just follow that me so we'll go
right through suffer the consequence
we've got to get to the care bed and
he's home whatever you say Myron and we
went and then we started laughing
because it was an open road we were
saying we had to back up we cause
traffic all the way back because we had
to back up come to find now we could've
took the open road so no one near our
map out your route
you know they're only going from there
going from Guatemala Honduras and El
Salvador ian's are coming through
and that's on the map that you seen up
here Digital smoke signals I made ground
contact on where to donate who's on the
ground
I mean contacting the journalist group
where I actually just have to translate
you're gonna be lucky cuz you read
Spanish and I could share that with you
that I was on the live feed on what I
wanted to do
I met anybody who volunteered that spoke
English and I asked them you know and
they who was they're consistent
consistently and then I went and talked
with the kitchens because at Standing
Rock we had like eight nine kitchens
that many people he only had one kitchen
the lines went just all I mean they were
crazy so you know there's solutions
I brought solutions that I wanted to
share so bring solutions and if you
don't crowdsource those solutions but be
very careful with your location I
I wouldn't say go alone the women were
not alone they were with groups of men
and that's important just for your
safety not saying that it wasn't a safe
place I didn't feel unsafe only in one
place of Mexico I felt unsafe but I
didn't feel unsafe until he told me I
was unsafe and then I was cautious but
that was my ignorance
and you're documenting the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
with media I started seeing myself
getting her harassed by attorneys to
show them how do we work with allies
there was a time when I wasn't very
comfortable at all because we're scared
of being token Indians and taking
advantage of our identity being used in
the media and to counteract indigenous
non native and indigenous media to
always do educating this is the
opportunity to educate and it was the
when I was checking in the media it was
an opportunity to educate and hear their
story and also that many of the people
that had their own historical trauma
America has huge historical trauma that
they're not dealing with and they're not
healing and and I want to I wanted to
share that I'm starting the healing
process me and a friend in the back of
names Heather who lives in Wahpeton
nation gonna raise your hand Heather she
is an original descendent of the
Mayflower and so I think she has more I
really put her on the spot to you know
cover that you got a hold your people
accountable so we share the solutions
and ideas that were trying to role model
what the healing process here not
everyone I said is ready for it and I
can tell you it took me most of my life
to be prepared to sit and and articulate
that and and it's not easy you know
because again the atrocities that come
so we have to use the media as a visual
legal narrative to make sure we can role
model these teachings with the role
model how to protect our ceremonies
because we're in a digital age again
that's where I started coming up with
digital protocols that were coming in
and what we could use the footage for
also when we go in academics our words
are being taken and used as ethno
historians and where the elders are
they're getting the credit they're not
getting the credit for it for me it's
pathologically biases what I feel
basically just straight up plagiarism
not citing their source so that's where
my Master's is the digital language
participate
is to make sure that we are citing our
sources so when you guys know you're in
Indian country cite your source it's
really simple and you're gonna give
credit where credit is due because many
of the voices and teachers have come
from indigenous people and I shared that
with the reporters as well document of
your on treaty land focus on the
eighteen eighteen sixty fifty-eight
treaties as focus on the where it's not
being held accountable why we're here
don't just say we're protesters and
we're actually telling you know where
water protectors why because I knew that
the police would take were protesting
and start saying we're inciting a riot
and when we incite a riot that North
Dakota the oil company will start to say
well after the actions were shutting
down the pipeline now we can claim
insurance no we're not gonna get let you
off that early that easy so we had to
articulate it in a way and to go around
and share with everybody that there is a
process here that is not working for
Americans that are taking advantage of
it in ways that you guys are letting
them so the visual legal narrative is
for you guys the solution to the problem
is you have to hold yourselves
accountable to hold your government
accountable to honor their promises to
us that's a solution and I can't stress
it enough we know what the problem is so
when you leave from here you need to
hold yourself accountable to understand
why we're in this fight and why we're in
this environmental change globally why
we're fighting for the water why we
can't drink the water anymore why we
can't swim in this water why you guys
switch to organic food instead of
harvesting your own food how we got
disconnected from our food source and
where we are economically today and why
we are in constant defense because we're
in poverty trying to protect our
homelands our children our food our
water that's why it's hard for us to
come out and it's I don't want you to
feel become attacking you I'm giving you
an opportunity to make it wrong right
I'm giving you a solution to say I can
do this and if you need help and if
you're stirring a little bit and you're
getting angry that's good because at
least you're filling some because you
need to
because what I witnessed is there's
children on people's backs on their
shoulders they're being kidnapped and I
could no longer stand by and acknowledge
that and say this is happening and when
I was down there some of the people did
oh don't don't give him money because
there's a next guy you're gonna run out
of money and also where do we get to
that point because I witnessed that
Standing Rock people from all over the
planet were coming and giving with their
bodies their voices their words their
legal help when I got arrested I have 25
attorneys volunteer imagine in our
history and indigenous history going
into a colonial court with the judge
that's non-native your representation
not native your jury not native and you
had 25 attorneys protecting you we
didn't have that and that's why so many
of our indigenous people are
incarcerated right now because we didn't
have that our natural law does not fit
into the colonial law they're not gonna
protect it as we've seen in Dakota
access pipeline as protecting our burial
sites the natural law as well we're
looking at the environmental injustice
that happened that we have protections
put in place I'm asking you guys to hold
this government accountable we're trying
to protect the water and the air and the
food sources we need your help to hold
yourself accountable if you're
non-native if you're from another
country then it is still your
responsibility to hold yourself
accountable than what you migrated here
what country you might migrate doesn't
matter Taiwan Japan Tokyo does not
matter Australia you still have a moral
obligation to protect the land that
you're on you're witnessing indigenous
people do it I'm asking you to hold
yourself accountable you can do it
because you have more than what I
witness people just all they had what
was on their backs and I've seen people
do it when they were to stand around the
hitchhike one couple did it with a boxes
of donations
you know churches came and apologized
for the doctrine of discovery and the
atrocities that happened in this
country's built upon veterans came and
apologized for being on the wrong side
of history and apologized for the past
atrocities that happened so I seen
people do it and I know you can do it so
it just takes one spark in you to say
you know what
I'm gonna start with myself and say I
apologize for what my tribe has done I
don't you guys been in Nevada but you
know we were one of the last ones
already were were hit with colonisation
and I can't speak for the tribes that
are no longer a part of a part of that
voice because they were completely
exterminated so those were our relatives
those are our brothers and sisters and
and the progress of of the Gold Rush
well you guys seen that is still
happening today what they're calling and
different types of gold rushes and Tesla
just moved in as we move into
sustainability you guys are gonna wonder
where the the minerals are gonna come
they're coming from Paiute country so
attraction in us moving in a direction
we have to have an agreement I'm
thinking 50 years down the road this
framework needs to be built this is a
seven generation where the answer to our
ancestors prayers now together we're
gonna have to start building the
framework for the next seven generations
so they can be the answers to our
prayers and this is something that's
been repeated by our elders many many
times and it's gonna take time you guys
in the back that do visual media put
together conscious media not just visual
media there he needs to be a conscious
media in MIT that has awareness and has
substance community journalism as a
collective not as an individual so when
our sister goes down there to film she
know she's part of a collective we just
introduced that we're gonna role model
I've never met her before but she's
gonna I know that I'm gonna connect with
people down there and do what we can to
share the story and amplify it so I hope
that answered your question there oh
which I have been interpreted like like
clearly
long-term
long-term
and sometimes it feels like you know
streaming live feed into that
part of the sentences could you kind of
talk like that in filming versus
well who controls the media controls the
narrative in the culture you know so
Hollywood has done a really great
example of romanticize in the Indian and
so I had to make sure I worked with
Hollywood there and we had disagreements
it was they one of my editors you know
was one of their editors we canwe
indigenized her an open Freder mine and
we got into it when I first met her I
was like you know I I'm not gonna use
less than Mojica me sickness you know
and and and the guy that was there he
was really nice he was really nice and
you know he was just real gentle and I
said well ha maybe I can work with this
guy I left and I came back and I heard
how he talked to his crew but he was not
a nice guy he's not very polite not
respectful he didn't take care of them
and a place where taking care of each
other I was witnessing that not
happening to the Allies that were coming
in then when I came back in he was back
to his place and I said I'm not gonna do
it I held my ground I'm not gonna let
you romanticize us again and change the
message we have original singers here
people and elders that can articulate
it's academically professionally legally
culturally spiritually United as a
collective and so he we we argued an
argument finally he came down to kicking
everything out and just the native guy
that was playing flute you know and I
said we got flute players here why don't
you use anybody that say I'm a flute
player this guy's a flute player we got
drummers singers cultural appropriation
and the media was happening we had to
stop it
you know and that's by educating so I
was willing to have the patience to
educate I'm a historical trauma trainer
I train the trainer's the goal is to
really help as well as myself I'm still
learning you know we have that
patriarchy way of thinking and to get
away from that we're matriarchal tribe
so we still have that way of thinking
every now and then so I want to make
sure that you know that you understand
that that's that's in the Western
culture and it's in our daily lives
sometimes and we don't even know it and
I struggle with it at times
I'm trying to survive as well that's the
colonized thinking I'm trying to
decolonize and also know much tsunami
realized my mind so I can go on that
process and start healing my spirit and
it's hard because sometimes I got out
white man the white men and then go read
traditional eyes you know and it's not
easy and coming back to it I got to
remember you know and be humble and then
open that open that door for somebody
else and pull them through because in
Western culture you're not taught that
you're not taught that you're an
individual you know you're shooting for
the American dream which you got to be
dreaming to experience so I hope that
answers your question is you know
educating in the media and to make sure
that you know for me as an indigenous
filmmaker or storyteller digital
storyteller I was born in the second
decade of the 21st century right now is
where I'm at I was in mourning eighteen
hundred's although I can you recall the
stories that were told by my tribe or my
elders or my grandma my uncles my family
or stories of our community I can still
share that with you we still have those
so I'm gonna continue to share with you
we have our creation stories predating
in Western contact stories of dinosaur
stories when the water was high I'm
gonna share that with you we're still
practicing our ceremony I was born in a
baby basket made out of willows off of
the land that we can no longer harvest
because of the contamination of the
willows you know we used to have fish in
our lake that we could no longer eat or
call the guy together but I'm gonna show
it to you in film I want to show it to
you in media I'm gonna educate you and
if you can open your heart and mind that
I'm still here and I'm not in the past
I'm still here today then then we're
gonna change that paradigm shift and I'm
hoping we can do that by digital
storytelling is it the answer no it's
not the answer but it is part of the
solution to the problem
language the loss of dignity systemic
racism and the education the things that
we see in cultural appropriation which
you guys are going to see your kids that
are gonna start coming back dressed like
Indians or pilgrims or the artwork
that's another example about it this is
not okay
educate yourself about that that's not
okay because you're carrying on false a
narrative there the food deserts are in
our most reservations they're there like
in theirs there's a lack of traditional
foods in there and the
turn-of-the-century the government was
given tribes food rations that were
killing us creating diabetes golf stones
cholesterol blood sugar all these issues
that we're seeing in this generation
right now and now we're kind of flipping
it back some tribes have more access to
their foods than others but it's still
so expensive that it is easier to go to
Walmart and it's easier to go to the
smoke shop and get these foods that are
not healthy and that's mostly in
low-income communities it's cheaper to
go get this toxic food than it is to get
healthier food and that's the food
desert on the reservations but we're
trying to create community gardens and
China trying to create most of Indian
countries moving into that direction
they're trying to get us to eat tilapia
which is not our food you know we're
trout eaters so I just like listen we
got to create a solution here so my
hippie buddies I'm like you guys got to
create a solution with us if you want to
work with us you can't make us think the
way you're thinking we don't think that
way so you know we can't go hug a tree
but we know it's got energy you know
we're gonna we're gonna know we're gonna
pray and the way we were taught that is
taught to us as time than worn away
before Western contact those original
instructions of the Creator so that's
the food desert part is our medicine is
it get back away from those and then try
to have a community garden that we do
hoop houses
and but it's getting harder and harder
because the land is contaminated and
there's no way for them to roam and move
like they used to we can no longer hunt
deer the rabbits are contaminated as
well at a certain time of season you can
eat them so there's sort of some
challenges I hate to be the debbie
downer on that but we're trying and as
we keep moving forward is gonna have to
continue to just find solutions
so for like myself after Standing Rock I
didn't realize I had heavy PTSD and many
water protectors did but you know also
where we have PTSD already throughout
Indian country from what we experienced
from boarding schools and we got almost
almost used to VIP but this was a
different level protecting each other
though like the communication like this
and social media and what she gets down
there and does for her media and she can
share where she's at and we can actually
send people over to help her or making
sure you're in alignment with people
healers are also going down to work with
the people down there people have been
reaching that we're sending healers down
there to share the energy and to help
them as well
bilingual healers which is really
awesome so there's a lot of allies
jumping on board with solutions that are
decolonizing
again you have to recognize your
colonise what are the colonized ways
you're bringing or are you what are you
are you bringing a solution as a
collective or you're part of a team or
are you going down as an individual so
those are the things I would say if
you're gonna work with indigenous people
think of those really small things that
are huge because it does impact how we
think and how we take care of each other
that album you so there's different ways
of healing I found different ways to
heal and I went and family was medicine
and being back at home in the land some
things retriggered like the plane that
flew 24/7 the helicopter all said I'm
thinking a standing rock think sometimes
when I watch a certain thing on TV and I
see propaganda media that's why I went
down there I wanted to counteract it and
show grassroots community journalism
those things and I don't see a healing
component in medium that you do you know
I don't see it in there I don't see that
um those natural laws to help us feel
good and that's what we need to see and
I think that's what community journalism
is doing is the healing process
we have that word we call it a an
initiative hi which is like your breath
of life and and it's like your your
whatever you say is so important it's
got medicine and it carries so I might
say wow that is a beautiful scarf
you'll wear and see the smile comes
right on that's the medicine that we
have to each other
individuals
they they use it as a stepping stone
I would say I can only use my own
experience you know in the beginning I
would grab a lot of protectors and say
this person was on the front line as for
us it's ego right you're talking about
ego and when you go home when I go home
anyways my ego is checked no one cares
what I did
and I love it because you know I can I
can be Who I am back home and that's
what it's about is checking our ego
making sure you know one of the biggest
things is why did you come here I stand
here on earth you know I came there to
film and use media to help protect our
people protect the water I went to
Mexico to help see to help amplify a
message that I was seeing wasn't being
amplified it wasn't about me when it's
about me then it's ego this message is
about water protectors this mess is
about educating as much as we can and if
we can counteract that ego then how we
can do it in a good way the other thing
is how we're a cat
you know social media you can get
attacked death threats
I've had several death threats people
attack me and follow through with the
attacks and our own people the jealousy
that comes up in the movement it's your
own people they're a part of that and I
acknowledge that I've got work to do
so I'm like always like trying to see
how can I improve what I'm doing and my
saying the right thing and my amplifying
someone's message because it's not about
me it's about what we're protecting but
ego was the most important one you got
to check and if you can't and I've seen
people you know what say hey brother you
know you got a you know we have this
talk and then the whole sudden they're
like oh they get mad I'm saying hey it's
not about you you know it's about what
you're protecting you made it about you
I'm just sharing with you and that's
been done to me with others you know I
have a group of elders to help me keep
me in check and I'll call them and say
you know I want to make sure I'm saying
the right things or you watch it yes
okay am I am i sharing the water
protector story
okay we had 838 water protectors it was
not about me after without all movement
it was about the safety and the freedom
of water protectors that came and also
our allies that stood with us that's
what it was about after this I kept
standing I was there for eight months
afterwards the documentary is so that it
couldn't they didn't have to keep
calling me you know for footage and
media because I put most of it in there
to make sure that also people who wasn't
incriminated so yeah social media does
do that and it does sensationalize but
if you can check your ego and if you
have a good circle that can check you
and I'm fortunate I met people from
black lives matter or Occupy Wall Street
that told me here's what's gonna happen
after this is standing rock because
everyone went home here's what's gonna
happen because this is what happened
with them in the American Indian
Movement it's us where we attack each
other where did the money go
can you share some things that were
shared to me where did the money go man
how did you get rich off awake you know
well many people don't know after I
leave MIT I'm going to Train which we
created a youth media fund to Train
frontline media that's where it went we
have to role model to change because
I've seen it in our communities all the
time when a new leader comes into
position I'll look at this guy he's
driving in your car instead of thinking
I'm glad his car can make it to the
state capital represent us I'm glad he
can you know get there as long as he's
doing this job so we have a lot of
healing to do and I'm learning how to
also there's some of the places where I
come I come in and I don't have that the
tools so I have to humble up myself as
well and go get those tools I'm a father
so I look at like I'm abandoning my
family as well by doing this so I have
to make sure that I stay balanced and
and that I don't take away there's a lot
of sacrifice and what we do and it's and
and I'm praying that I do it in a good
way and I'm sharing the stories of
people that don't have the voice and I'm
hoping that I use that platform that I
can share as much as I possibly can
and a good way and if I get ego you come
and check me please I really I mean I'm
serious
you can share with me mine I wish you
would share a little bit more about this
and I admit that I don't have some of
the information and knowledge to do it
but I will try I will do what I can to
share that platform